Narrator: Nostalgia Critic: critic of nostalgia.
Searching for a movie to tap into the inner frustrations every movie nerd has.
Then, a viewing of a fascinatingly misdirected movie alters his chemistry.
And now, whenever he hears any mention of the movie Hulk, a startling metamorphosis occurs.
NC: Malcolm.
Tamara.
Do not show me that movie.
You wouldn't like me when you show me that movie.
I exploded.
Narrator: The Critic is wanted for property damage he didn't commit.
Well, OK, he did, but it was just of a movie
and that movie sucked.
The Critic's patience is believed to be dead.
And he must let the world believe it is dead
until he can find a way to control the whiny
bitch fits that dwells within him.
NC: Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
You know, this should be the easiest guy to make interesting.
The Incredible Hulk is a classic Jekyll and Hyde story about scientist Bruce Banner
whose experiment goes wrong and turns into a giant green monster whenever he gets angry.
It has both the psychological AND physical elements that usually make for great classic storytelling.
Yet his cinematic ventures have been so underwhelming that
despite him being many people's favorite parts in other movies
no solo movies are planned in the near future.
And that all started with the
"HNNGH!"
simply known as Hulk.
How can a story about a giant green monster be boring?
That was the challenge presumably given to director Ang Lee.
He just finished a winning streak with his martial arts opus, Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon,
winning over box office, critics, and
too many awards to count.
So producers immediately said, "That!"
"We want that for our action-packed Hulk movie!".
But what they were missing is that Ang Lee usually did social dramas.
He did Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon because he always wanted to do a martial arts movie.
One.
One martial arts movie.
He brushed up for YEARS on martial arts flicks so he could figure out how to do it right.
With Hulk, very clearly, he was a director-for-hire.
And saw this more as a means to experiment rather than bring a lifelong dream to life.
And much like Bruce Banner, this experiment WOULD haunt him for the rest of his days.
He certainly recovered and returned back to his comfort zone
but the mark this movie left on comic fans is probably the most uniquely bad since this:
"This is why Superman works alone."
But while that was bright and colorful and
at least made little kids happy, this...
would only make that kid who stands in the corner saying "I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad." happy.
Because he's gonna set someone on fire.
So, why is this the most intriguing, and yet somehow, also most boring of missteps?
Well, let's make everybody angry with "Hulk."
Whoa, whoa! Tone down those expectations there!
This is not the movie you're going to get!
No, let's instead do those early 2000's credits of blurry closeups mixed with sped up and slowed down editing.
I've always wanted to see an intro with my glasses off and a monkey playing with the remote.
OK, Coco, push play. Push play.
No, now you're fast-forwarding.
No, no, now you're slowing it down.
No, now you have it on extreme zoom.
Extreme zoom.
No, no, pull it back to normal.
This is the best way to watch this movie!
Oh, and if you think this style is only done in the credits
your senses are in for a bludgeoning!
Because there's gimmicky editing techniques throughout the entire film.
And I mean the ENTIRE film.
Just look at this flashback of Bruce Banner's father.
Edith:​ I'm gonna have a baby.
If you find this mildly annoying, then just add 2 hours of it and
that M will quickly turn upside-down.
Like me, you might be wondering, "What's the point of all these transition tricks?".
Tricksitions as I like to call them.
My best guess is Ang Lee wanted to create the closest thing he could to a comic book.
Meaning the film literally has panels, speed lines, and elements of space and time overlapping each other.
There's just one problem with that, though.
If you're adapting a book
would you constantly put words all over the goddamn place?
This is way too friggin' literal!
Ross: Gamma decontamination will occur in 30 minutes.
NC: Actually, I take it back.
There's 2 problems with this technique.
In a comic book, these are used to suck you more into the story.
It leaps off the page and brings you into their reality.
This is constantly taking you out of what's going on.
You can't ever breathe in the world because the movie's too busy trying to physically show you the lines that they're supposed to be breathing in!
Ross: Gamma decontamination will occur in 30 minute-
NC: Actually, I take it back.
There's 3 problems with this.
I'm sorry to dwell on this so much, but this is literally throughout the whole goddamn film.
It's best to tackle it in one "Unh!".
Other movies like "Spider-Man" and "Sin City" look like the comics they portrayed to create a stronger environment for their world.
They're adventurous, they're action packed, they're totally over the top.
You know what this film mostly consists of?
Bruce: Are we passing inspection?
Harper: Safeties all going green...
NC: THAT!
A LOT OF SITTING AROUND AND TALKING!
So the style doesn't even match the tone!
It's like they realized there's no friggin' excitement in this flick
so to remind you it's even supposed to be a comic book film they're like:
"Umm..."
"Pffft"
"Throw some comic sans in there, put that frame there, that frame over there, and"
"make it look like The Brady Bunch."
Comics! We get this!
Little Bruce: RAWR!
*Growling and Grumbling*
NC: Uh, on second thought, maybe we don't.
Where the hell was there a comic that had imagery like that?
Maybe if I read it while doing this.
Also I don't think TREES are a big focus of comics.
We're
...really putting the camera on this?
We're this bored this early?
Unless this is Treebeard's porn stache
WHY ARE YOU SHOOTING THAT!?
So something happens in Bruce's past that he's repressed, and
with his dad taking his mother screaming into the back, you can probably guess what it is.
Oh!  I mean
I'm gonna spend the whole entire film wondering what that
He kills his mom!
Come on!
It even cuts immediately to a foster home when he's a teen.
You think we couldn't figure this out?
Though, to their credit, maybe his stepmom's disinterest is supposed to distract us from connecting the dots.
Mrs. Krenzler: There's something inside you.
So special.
Some kind of greatness
...I'm sure. And some day you're gonna
...share it with the whole world.
NC (as director): Okay, cut!
That was good, but, uh, let's try something a little different here this time.
Let's try
trying.
Though, don't worry, stepmother.
The award for the least amount of effort clearly goes to Jennifer Connelly.
I get the feeling, every day she showed up to the set and the crew was like
(as director): Okay, Connelly!
Uh, are we gonna act today or not act today?
Betty: There was some sort of explosion.
They wouldn't let us into the building.
I was worried about you.
NC (as director): Not act today.
Okay.  It's a not acting day everybody!
We just wanted to know how to shoot it to make you look
"...invested."
(himself) Hell, I think the most gripping performances of the movie probably come from these two.
Stan Lee: Security ought to be beefed up a lot more, in a place like this.
NC: I really believed he wanted tighter security.
And I really believe that Lou Ferrigno was
...umm
...looking at him.
Okay, I didn't even believe that
but he looked like THIS for years!
He gets a pass!
By the way, minus two points for even
your credits not being consistent!
When even your font doesn't know what it wants to be, you're kind of in trouble.
Harper: Bruce!
Big day.
Did ya sleep?
NC: We find out that Bruce, played by Eric Bana
is working on ways to expose gamma rays to electro-energy gigawatts capacitor-
Sciencey shit where somehow superpowers are the wrong answer.
They try their experiment on a frog and discover the results are a little too explosive.
Somebody call Miss Piggy, there's been an
"...accident."
Bruce: You want to tell the review board that we've developed a brand-new method for exploding frogs?
Betty: Yeah.
Think maybe there's a market for it.
Frogs start falling from the sky
who do they come to?
NC: Oh HA HA HA HA HA!
No. Really.
Suck of it while you can.
That's the only joke in the entire movie.
Oh! Excuse me.
There's a bookmark of a man reading fighting for space.
Okay, if you're really gonna draw this much attention to your transitions
I'm gonna draw even more attention to it by putting in the goofy sound effects they deserve!
[high pitch whistle]
[stretching metal]
[fast whistle]
Glenn: Betty!
[Squish?]
[poke]
[crash]
NC: This dick-face McSmearSmirk is Glenn.  He's...
do exactly what you think he's gonna do:
try and steal Banner's girlfriend
get in the way of his experiment
and waste a LOT of time trying to explain every boring reason why.
Glenn: So how's business?
Betty: What do you want?
Glenn: Your little molecular machines have some incredible implications.
How'd you like to come work for Atheon?
Get paid ten times as much as you are now.
NC: The HULK!
People calmly discussing things!
Staring at each other in silence!
But
...L-look!
Green walls!
It's...kind of like the Hulk is there!
Symbolically!
Oh you just don't get it!
You don't understand the layers of subtlety and conversation that need to be had with...
Ooh, look! It's the film's first big surprise!
They got a new janitor!
Betty: Hey what happened to Benny?
Is he not working the night shift anymore?
???: I'm the new guy.
NC: That's exciting!
Betty: Good to meet you.
???: Same.
NC: Ah.
The classic "mop" transition I see 'so' often in comics.
Man, it's a good thing nobody takes a shit in this movie.
So Bruce sits around staring at old pictures of Connelly as his girlfriend-
OH COME ON!!
Even the Kodak film has to run through the pretentious filter?!
I'm just waiting for the Prisoner of Azkaban to knock him out with a bottle of butterbeer!
This results in a flashback of when Bruce and her were still dating.
Bruce: Tell me about your dream.
Betty: Starts with a memory from when I was maybe two years old.
[cartoon running]
I was living at a desert base with my father.
Suddenly I'm alone.
Talking about dreams!
Reoccurring dreams!
With your boyfriend being your father and trying to strangle you-
pkpikp
What?!
Bruce: That's terrible
You know I'd never hurt you.
NC: Okay, um.
Anyone that's new to the dating scene;
I don't know what Ang Lee is trying to tell you, but
if your date says they have a reoccurring dream about you as their father trying to kill them as a small child
Out.
Just get out.
Don't even make up an excuse.
Just FLEE!
The only person you should flee faster from is Nick Nolte-
Of course he's in this movie!
Mr. Banner (played by Nolte): You may not want to believe it, but I can see it.
Nolte plays Banner's real dad.
I'm not sure if he went crazy then did the film or if he did the film then went crazy, but
there's regret to be had all around.
I guess he's supposed to be intimidating, but
it doesn't really help when you're stalking a guy with three cuddly dogs by your side.
No, seriously.
This was supposed to be a threatening image!
I'm sorry!
The dogs goddamn ruin it!
Banner is so intimidated by this that he actually closes the blinds.
Why?!
Even the most paranoid person wouldn't muster a sweat from this!
*snicker*
Tamara: What is that?
*laughing*
What is that?!
Hey buddy!
"Best in Show" is down the street!
*laughing*
When are you gonna break out a baton and have them bark "Ode to Joy?"
*more laughter*
Oh thank God they're gone.
I thought I was gonna die of laughter.
Whoo!
They really need to be in a Hulk movie.
NC: Bruce walks in to find Smooth Suit McEeeeeeh
who wants to weaponize his ability to blow up frogs.
Betty: About Glenn.
I um...
Bruce: There's nothing to talk about.
NC: Oh.
Good.
THEN DO SOMETHING!
Jesus!  We're a half hour in and not only has no action happened, but
Think about it.
What do we really know about Bruce Banner?
He
...fondles babies in other people's dreams.
Well that's the most I'm getting out of it!
Oh no!  Something's happening!
Stop!  Before it leads to the dangers of interest!
Bruce: Harper, get out!
The experiment seems to go wonky and Bruce sacrifices himself to a Photoshop filter.
No, really.  It's this one. *snap*
See?
Finally leading him to transforming into
a guy in a hospital bed-
OH MY GOD!
Bruce: How's Harper?
Betty: He's alright.
NC: "How's Harper?"
"He's alright."
"We're gonna sell so many toys!"
Mr. Banner: Your name is not Krenzler.
NC: But hospital security is proving it's worth every penny as Nick Nolte and his
...presumably extended family, sneak in to see Bruce.
Mr. Banner: You've had a terrible accident.
Bruce: So perhaps you should leave now.
Mr. Banner: We're gonna have to watch that "temper" of yours.
NC: Yes, Lord knows, this really seems like a guy who flies off the handle!
Bruce: I'll be fine.
NC: Whoa, hey! Watch it!
That faint whisper almost turned into a dull roar!
Connelly agrees to meet with her father, played by Sam Elliott-
WHOA! A CAR!!
Sorry, this movie's so dull, I confused that for an action sequence.
Who is also interested in their scientific discoveries.
Gen. Thunderbolt  Ross: Look I'm gonna
get right to it.
This "Krinsler" you work with...
You know who he really is?
How much do you actually know about him?
NC: You ever notice how Sam Elliott talks like he has one last bite of steak in his mouth?
(Gen. Ross mumbling) Well right now, I'm not at liberty to-
NC: Yeah, yeah. Chew.
(Gen. Ross mumbling)
Chew and swallow.
Chew and swallow!
(Gen. Ross mumbling)
It's rude to act with your mouth full!
Don't make Marvel waste you in another movie.
Betty: Maybe this time you just honestly wanted to see me again?
Gen. Ross: I do want to see you.
Betty: I really wish that I could believe you.
The teaser that literally looked like this:
[CRASHING AND ROARING]
...was literally representing
THIS!
The funny thing is, we're about 45 minutes in.
Well, okay.
I guess they're doing the "Jaws" effect and trying to build up the green guy's appearance.
But here's the thing.
When he does finally change, it happens right the hell out of nowhere!
Yeah!  He's just sitting at his computer doing work and suddenly he's like:
(as Bruce): Shit, dammit!
I WANT THE HULK!
There's only so long we could pretend we know what we're talking about!
Deliver the Green M&M on Shrek-oids!
(himself): Yeah. That's great. That's great.
We waited 45 minutes to see this damn thing.
Please focus on the beaker.
That is clearly what we want to look at.
You know when Jaws did show up,
they didn't focus on the life preserver!
Whoo! Okay. He's here.
Christ.
We finally got him.
At friggin' long last, here is the Hulk.
Get him the hell out of here!
We gotta change him back as fast as possible for more boring conversations!
Betty: Were you at the lab?
Bruce: There was that man.
Betty: Who?
Bruce: That new janitor.
Bruce: The one with the dogs.
NC: Christ, I can't take this anymore.
I need a break.
Here's some people that know how to sell something fun BETTER than this goddamn movie!
Commercial: Hey, kids!
You want something smashin'?
Kids: Yeeeaah!
Commercial: Well, crash your way to excitement with the Hulk!
Now that you have everyone's favorite crushing machine
what are you gonna do with him?
Malcolm (as Cliff): I'm think about the repressed memories that might be hiding in my psyche.
Commercial: Um... okay.
Hey, little girl!
What are you going to do with him?
Tamara (as Melody): I'm gonna use him as justification to finally confront my domineering father.
Cliff: Melody, that's so brave of you.
Melody: Thank you, Cliff.
Commercial: Well, uh...
Doesn't anyone want to use him for smashing and stopping the forces of evil?
Melody: Shh!
Can't you see he's distraught!
Cliff: I can't believe we're losing the grant money.
Melody: It's okay, Cliff. We'll think of something.
Cliff: Will we?
Or will we be lost to the visual representation of our own sub-conscience?
Melody: Oh, Cliff!
Cliff: (crying) Melody.
Commercial: The Hulk!
It's
...as much fun as it looks?
Cliff: We're done with childish things.
Melody: Oh.
NC: So as mentioned before, Connelly visits to explain what happened.
Betty: What happened to you last night?
Bruce: It was like being born.
It was like
Boom.
NC (as Betty): Reacting by not reacting...
Done.
(himself): But it looks like Elliott thinks Bruce might be behind the lab being destroyed.
(as a bodyguard): We have no idea what your father is saying, ma'am.
Can you help us?
Gen. Ross: Mitchell, escort my daughter outside.
I'll join her shortly.
NC: Chew and swallow!
Betty: And that's for the new guy on the night shift?
[aroused whistle?]
[boing]
NC: Connelly goes to Nick Nolte's house-
filmed presumably on location at Nick Nolte's house-
as she discovers he's Bruce's father, and they have a competition for who can speak the softest.
Mr Banner: (whispering) Cure him.
Change him.
Betty: He seems to think he's involved in some kind of threat to national security.
Mr. Banner: My son is...
unique.
NC (as Mr. Banner): He was born without a personality.
Actually, that's not very unique in this movie.
Mr. Banner: And a very beautiful woman like you,
your intentions can be completely unwanted.
NC (as Mr. Banner): You make the fleas in my beard go crazy.
Mr. Banner: Besides...
he's made it clear he wants nothing to do with me.
NC (as Betty): Yeah, I can clearly see that you took my scarf,
as displayed by this shot of me clearly seeing you taking my scarf.
Mr. Banner: I have some work to do.
NC (still as Betty): I'm...not asking for it back?
Director?
I mean, you focused on it.
You actually showed a scene of me seeing him take it.
I'm...not retrieving what was touched by Nick Nolte's dirty, disease-filled hands-
You know what, he can keep it.
(himself) He uses the scarf to give her scent to
...the beast from Sandlot?
...as cops surround Banner's house, keeping him under house arrest.
Glenn: Asshole, I want to talk to you!
Doing a bang-up job as you can see.
Oh no!  The cops should call the cops!
Bruce: Talbot.
Glenn: Yeah?
Bruce: You're making me angry!
NC (as Bruce): How dare you make me feel an emotion in this film!
(as Glenn): Mr. Giant,
I swear I ate all my vegetables.
AAAAH!!
(himself) He makes his way to Connelly's house, who's reaction is
(sigh) ...exactly how it is in the rest of the film.
NC (as director): Cut! Okay Connelly, let's try something a little different here. Um
ACT!!!
(himself) God above!
I would have gone through at least the majority of the Three Stooges' reactions at this point!
Haphaphaphaphap!
Nyahnyahnyah!
A tarantula!
(himself) Oh, but for some reason you thought THAT didn't deserve a big reaction,
how about this?
ZUUL, MOTHERFU-
Oh, my God? Are you serious?
That-that's not the final thing, is it? Oh, sorry.
*clears throat*
ZUUL, MOTHERFU-
(laughing) What is this!?
Guys!
Guys, come on!
No!
(himself) Yup.
This is the first action sequence in the movie,
One hour in,
and he's fighting mutant Pound Puppies.
Isn't this always what you wanted?
When you saw the Incredible Hulk on TV and cartoons and in the comics
weren't you always wishing for the big screen adaptation where he fought the zombie cast of Lady and the Tramp?
You just know Stan Lee was watching the dailies of this and was like:
(as Stan Lee): Ang, I know you directed Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon. Uh...
Is there any chance you can actually put in a crouching tiger or a hidden dragon?
I'm just saying.
I created Stripperella.
And even I'm finding this pretty dumb.
(himself): So the Hulk defeats the mutant poodle.
...something that I didn't think I'd say while watching this,
...and changes back, because, by God, we haven't see enough of him as a normal guy yet, have we?
Betty: What were those animals?
NC: Well, I believe the scientific term is
"ridiculous."
But Elliott tranquilizes him and takes him to his base where he keeps him out cold
much to his daughter's dismay.
Betty: He saved my life.
Ross: Yeah, from a mutant French poodle.
I'm indebted to him for that.
NC: You know, Sam, you almost made that stupid line work.
But you didn't.
You still had to say the words "mutant French poodle."
But it was a good try.
Nolte experiments on himself trying to continue Bruce's work, allowing him to physically adapt to his surroundings.
This, in all honesty, leads to maybe the only cool scene in the movie.
Goddammit!
Why'd that cool hand had to be attached to Nick Nolte?
And why'd that Nick Nolte had to be attached to this film?!
Don't worry, though.
They give you more of exactly what you came here for:
friggin' talking!
Only this time, there's an army to stop any exciting development.
So there's no fear of that pesky joy!
Hell, I think even the soldiers would be shouting at them to get some action about now.
Betty: It's hard to believe we used to live here.
Bruce: l must have seen you or known you.
If only l could remember.
NC (as Soldier): Oh, my God!
Make him angry!
(as Soldier 2): Tell him the movie's gonna bomb!
(as Soldier 3): Tell him he's gonna be replaced by two actors!
TWO!
Bruce: This is my old house, isn't it?
NC: You know, you see that unused playground equipment that's supposed to be fun for kids
but is in the middle of an empty, lifeless wasteland?
I can't help but wonder if that's Ang Lee's symbolic cry for help.
The Huuuulk!!
Just
...have a good nap.
*snoring*
Gen. Ross: *yell*
How dare you wake me up!
I was having the most wonderful dream where I wasn't watching you!
So Glenn takes over the operation so he can weaponize the Hulk's DNA.
But while studying him, Bruce dives deep into his repressed memories and figures out the painful truth
...in that, it was
so painful how much we already knew the truth
...Bruce's dad kills his mom.
Mr. Banner: You cannot imagine the unbearable finality of it.
NC: Yeah, here's another big surprise:
(stage whispering) I think that's Wonder Woman!
He, of course, turns into the human Battletoad and he tries busting his way out.
But they have foam to stop him.
Because...
...if it makes bathtime fun, surely it can make the Hulk fun.
[Woody Woodpecker laugh]
(chuckling) Okay.
I think this scene only exists just to make a caption contest.
Like:
Wow, even by this movie's standards, that was a new level of
"What?!"
(as an announcer): Coming summer of 1977:
a spin-off of Charlie's Angels entitled.
Elliott does the sensible thing of releasing him unto the world
[OH, YEAH!]
And the military tries to take him down in the the desert.
(as the Hulk): To hell with this interpretive dance bullshit!
I GOTTA SMASH SOMETHING!
(chuckling) Okay.
I know the Hulk is supposed to be able to jump far, but
the way they do it, he looks like an unrendered Mario character!
[pixelated boing]
And we FINALLY get a little bit of Hulk actually fighting someone.
(as the soldier): Oh, my God! THAT WAS AMAZIIIiiing!
I am still falling.
We're just gonna hold on that shot
until you realize that looks like a penis.
Got it? Good.
Back to the action!
(as the pilot): Come back, or we won't give you a pointless romance with Black Widow!
Okay, fine!
You get a subtext romance with Thor!
But he makes his way to San Francisco
presumably to stop more seasons of Fuller House.
We then interrupt this thrilling action sequence to give you
shaving.
Was every scene based on a bet?
"Hey, I bet you can't do a Hulk movie where he fights a poodle."
"Hey, I bet you can't do a Hulk movie where he's stopped by bath products."
"Hey, I bet you can't do a Hulk movie where he shaves in the middle of a fight sequence."
Whoa, whoa, Ang!
I meant just try ONE of those bets in the movie!
I didn't know you do all three!
Oh, my God. There should be a defuse manual for the bomb you're making!
He, of course, keeps going and makes it to the city.
All right!
Now it's time to do some real damage.
Go rampage before Rampage mucks it up!
Or, in keeping on track, stop before you get to the actual cool stuff.
That works
...not at all.
(whispers) Blow him to hell.
(gunfire)
So Nolte is brought to his son, which obviously means the movie should focus on the conflict
between Nolte and Elliott.
Maybe they had a competition for who could be understood the least.
*imitating Elliot and Nolte with just "mer's" and "meh's."*
He's brought in to apparently take part in the stage play version of the film.
(as Mr. Banner): Bruce, what's your favorite word?
Bruce: Saw her face.
[boing]
Brown hair.
[WW2 bomb whistle]
Brown eyes.
[chomp]
NC: But, hey, let's have this two hours of suck go out on a high note!
As Nolte gives his best impression of Yosemite Sam swallowing a duck.
Mr. Banner: INFECTED HUMANITY'S SOUL!
Of the kind that walked the Earth!
DISAPPEAR!
TO ME!
MEN OUT THERE IN THEIR UNIFORMS!
NC (as Mr. Banner): I Hulk your MILKSHAKE!
Mr. Banner: THINK OF ALL THE HARM THEY'VE DONE!!
Mr. Banner: NYAAAHH!
NC: (laughs) Wow.
I don't think he could chew more scenery than if he literally picked up the set and started biting it-
Whoa! Whoa! I was just kidding!
Somebody should actually stop him before he eats himself!
He absorbs the electricity, making him super-powerful, and I'm
just gonna take a wild guess and say Connelly stares blankly at this.
I never thought I'd say this, but
Can we have this performance back?
Connelly (as Sarah): Someone has been in my room again.
I hate that.
I HATE IT!
NC: I can't promise it won't lead to this:
But at least it's an attempt!
Banner turns into the Hulk, and Nolte flies them away, absorbing whatever he touches.
It's the ultimate battle between father and son
even though there's
...surprisingly been very little time dedicated to them interacting as father and son.
So much has not been building up to this!
(as the Hulk): Hey, hey! We may be bad
but we're not Fant4stic yet!
(himself): Oh, my God! It's the audience's patience!
IT'S ABOUT TO BLOW!!
But the Army nukes them, and they're both presumed dead.
Connelly cares so little that she's lost her true love that she actually consoles her FATHER
rather than HER FATHER consoling HER!
(as Betty): When will I be more considerate about how my lack of feelings affects your feelings?
(himself) But, of course, they can't shake this feeling that Banner is still alive.
[cartoon running]
Gen. Ross: Look, uh.
If by some chance he
[boing]
did survive
[fart]
I'll try to contact you and, try to get in touch.
NC (as Ross): I know he's still out there...
The Bruce.
Taking it easy for us sinners.
(himself): And it looks like he is still out there, using his research to help others until somebody tries to stop him.
And roll those exciting-looking credits that in no way reflect the joyless mess that we just witnessed.
This movie's terrible!
It's the perfect definition of misguided.
It has some neat ideas, neat visuals,
and I'll even argue that one or two of those transitions could be very effective, clever, and even beautiful at times.
But there's just no thrill or investment.
Banner is not made an interesting character.
He's forgettable and bland.
Just like the rest of the characters.
And when you can't find them interesting, you can't find the film interesting
plain and simple.
I'm the Nostalgia Critic, and
...I need to journey to find better movies to watch.
Mr. Banner: NYAAAHH!
Hey! Doug Walker here doing the charity shoutout
and this week I'm doing a fan request.
This is for the Rainforest Foundation.
The Rainforest Foundation was founded on a new idea.
What if the indigenous people of the rainforest had the legal right to protect the forests we all depend on?
For a long time, environmental organizations didn't focus on human rights,
In fact, people were usually seen as part of the problem.
But this Foundation listened to the indigenous communities living deep in the Brazilian Amazon,
And decided to put their might behind fighting to protect their rainforest lands just as they always had.
Today, we know that rainforests protected by indigenous communities have the lower rates of deforestation than any other forests in the world.
Including national parks, national preserves, government land, and private sanctuaries.
So yes, rainforests can also be the homes to many many people, and we want to keep it that way.
If you look at their site and their Youtube channel, you can see all the people who benefit from the wonders of these incredible forests.
You can see how they live, how they thrive, and how they want to continue to do so.
Help protect these people and their homes.
Click on the link and see how you can be a big part of the solution.